just look at these baby goats I'm
showing them to you in the hope that
their cuteness will insulate you from
what you're about to see this is not a
baby goat it is in fact the larva of a
botfly
erupting out of human skin there are
several species of botfly that
parasitize a range of mammals from
horses to squirrels to you and me they
are I want to tell you horrible the
female botfly that targets horses lays
her eggs on the hive when the horse
licks the area it picks up the eggs
which hatch into larvae and attach to
its stomach
here's animation of another botfly that
tackles a mosquito mid-flight and
attaches her eggs to the insects belly
when the mosquito feeds on a human body
heat triggers the eggs to hatch into
larvae which burrow into the wound but
it poked its rump out of your skin so it
can poop which is courteous now you can
use tweezers to yank the botfly larvae
out but that will be uncomfortable
because it's covered in spines that
anchor in your flesh but if you let it
develop for three months or so it'll
back out on its own ideally it'll drop
into the soil and grow into an adult
starting the process all over again but
enough of that here's a goat on a green
screen he goat on a green screen
[Music]